all
Sorry.
Sorry!
Sorry, senpai!
Sorry, supplies!
It's okay, supplies!
Yeah, I'm fine, I'm fine, I'm fine, sorry, supplies!
I had my, I had my, I had my weekly breakdown just before stream!
Ugh, I tried my best.
I like, I like, did it, uh, I didn't cry.
Or like, oh shit, I don't remember which slot I saved in.
Uh, I like, uh, I didn't cry.
And then the moment I hit live, I like, transition, I was like, ah, fuck.
Just wait till I'm on my 19th, 19th nervous breakdown.
Oh yeah, oh yeah.
Oh yeah.
Or I gotta keep like, which one is the one that I saved in?
Oh, no data, okay, okay, yeah, okay.
I think I know which one, we're in, we're in this one.
So, yeah, let's load this file.
Look at those weekly hands!
I took my Walsh's sickness meds, yeah.
About half an hour before stream started.
I'm looking at a moon.
Ugh, okay.
Do I remember how this works?
Okay, that's movements.
Yes, okay.
Press A, hold A to continue.
Yes, yes, yes, I forgot!
Has your rash been feeling better?
Yeah, except for my doctor was like, except for now I'm starting at my rashes.
On my legs and my other arm.
And now I have an appointment with a dermatologist.
Yeah.
Wait, which way was I supposed to go?
I can't remember.
Oh, shit.
I can have your skin.
Here, I'll peel it off gently with a carving knife.
Oh, shit, was it this?
No, it was the other way.
It was the other way, tee-hee.
Boiler room.
Okay, let's see if I remember.
You happen to have any items from this level so far?
I don't remember.
Let's check.
Oh, items.
I have the firing equipeted.
I have some bloods.
And here's all the smiths.
I like using Dan the most because he's, he shoots fast.
He shoots at fast.
What the fuck is this?
F.
U.
Okay.
Input error.
Wait, was there a hint somewhere?
Was there a hint?
Oh, shit, reload.
Bit rude.
Was there a hint somewhere?
I like hints.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Wait, where is it?
Oh, yeah, there we go.
Oh, mommy.
Mommy, welcome to the stream Raiders.
There's an A.
Got drunk.
Good night, Mercy.
I love you, dear child.
She's so fucking drunk.
Oh, no.
Sampai.
Thank you for the 420, sending ton of love your way, Mercy.
You've continually been making my last few weeks better.
So thanks for that.
I also happen to be a resident of Manto, Illinois,
but you've helped bring me some stability
and something to look forward to more days.
Thank you.
Sampai's too.
Oh, my gosh.
Thank you for the five gifted.
Bui.
I was like, I was like,
oh, here's my like,
here's my like breakdown again.
Is there, is there something to do with these lights
or are they just there?
We can do okay.
Oh.
I don't know where K is in the alphabet.
Okay.
No.
Wait.
It's not ZK, is it?
It's not in ZK.
That would be so funny.
You see where the text says ISZK?
Oh, thank goodness it's not.
It would be so funny, but thank goodness it's not.
I know it's like, oh, we can totally,
we can totally brute force this,
but I want to solve it.
I want to solve it, Sampai.
Oh, well, I'm so stupid.
I remember.
Okay.
Yeah, we were, we were here.
I understand.
It was no understood.
It was no.
There you go.
Wow.
I for gore.
I for gore, Sampai.
It's been, what, like since last week?
Nampai.
Thank you for the super chat.
Chrono time.
Thank you.
You make the long days better.
Thank you, Mercy.
I for gore.
Correct input.
Lock deactivated.
This is my fault for like,
what's the word?
Oh, hey.
Oh, wait, it's different than a duplicate.
It's an evolved heaven smile with boosted explosive power.
You got to take it out before it gets too close.
They're crazy.
I'm telling you.
They'll be on top of you the moment you open the damn door.
Wait, can you say that again?
With this time, like more, more sash, sashual?
Okay.
This is where the queen is.
It's different than a duplicate.
An evolved heaven smile with boosted explosive power.
You got to take it out before it gets too close.
They're crazy.
I'm telling you.
They'll be on top of you the moment you open the door.
Well, shit, stairs.
Senpai, I might be fucking stupid.
I might be fucking stupid.
He said a door.
As soon as you get through the door, there was no fucking door.
I was like, what fucking door?
I'm going back.
I forgot how to heal.
Blood recovery.
Okay, there we go.
Okay.
Door equals stairs.
When he said door, I was like, oh, door, door, not stairs, corridor.
Fuck.
Am I kind of stupid?
Yes.
I didn't realize there was another corridor.
Which?
Which one?
There you are.
Okay, we're good.
I'm baffled by angles.
Can I go into Hyraman's room?
Oh.
Hi.
I'm on a go to the television now.
And please take the blood.
I can't save here, but I have some serum.
So I can...
I want to use my skills.
Let's do some...
I think I should put in criticals now.
Yeah, yeah, fuck you.
Yeah, I can do counter attacks.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And speed or waver or power.
Waver is the wiggliness.
No, no, I don't have enough to have more power.
Maybe less wiggly, so we'll do the waver.
Okay.
Counter attack.
Okay, cool.
No, I did not.
Okay, we need any more blood now.
Ah, shit, which...
Which way did I go?
I forgot again.
Whoo!
The other way, wasn't it?
It was the other way.
Oh my gosh.
You scared me, bondage son.
Iwa, Iwazaru.
Master, we're in a tight spot.
Things are turning in a bad way.
An infamous criminal lies this way.
And he's protecting him.
Wicked bad partners, indeed, indeed.
Ah, yes.
Seek out the soul shells.
With soul shells.
He was sure to allow you in the name of Harman.
I didn't read that fast.
How fucked am I, Senpai?
Wait.
Let me go back.
Again.
And...
Iwazaru, I need to look at the instructions again.
Okay, master, blah blah blah.
Blood is scary stuff.
Without blood, there is no tomorrow.
Because how do I do the special again?
Personas can absorb the blood out of the enemy.
Access stabilizer to help handle multiple personalities.
Without blood, your very life is in danger.
Press start slash pause to check blood volume.
You must use blood wisely in the name of Harman.
Special aim plus Y button three times plus shoot.
Oh yeah!
Let me just refresh it again anyways.
Yeah, Dan's special attacks.
Okay, Helian Dan loves destruction.
He's bound to destroy the enemy's nest.
Press the Y button three times.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Holding the gun with the R button.
Free test tubes will be equipped.
Use the A button to launch a demon shell.
Got it, got it, got it.
The red and yellow cores indicate the nest's weak points.
The name of Harman.
Oh, whoa, whoa.
I'm starting to remember slowly.
It was this holly.
Where's the yellow? Oh, there it is.
That was just me practicing, yeah.
Yeah.
Hello.
Gatekeeper.
Gatekeeper, girl boss, gaslet.
Hi.
Next please.
Where to?
Do the vinculum gate?
Let me take those.
Yes, R received.
Go right inside.
Nah, I got it.
Lost fight.
Fuck it.
Wait, this music poppin'.
Yeah.
It's a pop.
Hello.
Hi, it was Aru.
Master, we're in a tight spot.
Ain't even funny how tight it is.
Once you open the door, there's no turning back, master.
Well, you can come back, but I mean that's the gravity of the situation.
Don't get me wrong.
Like a prelude to later battles, you know?
You must take it very seriously.
The name of Harmon.
Please help me.
That monster is quick as lightning.
I tried my best to run away,
but it caught up with me anyway.
Hey, kill it before it explodes.
No, I'm gonna die again today.
Somebody please help.
Should I?
Here we go.
Shit, shit. Wow, speed smile, huh?
Oh, shit.
So we better go to Harmon's room.
Okay, okay, okay.
Spot A.
Yes, we overwrite this file.
We need anything else?
Probably not, but I do have a save file just in case.
Let's get in.
Permission to help if you need it, only if I need it.
They got cameras.
Wait.
Am I gonna be okay?
Is Garcia gonna be okay?
Hello talk. Oh, there you are.
Don't be shy, Amir.
Who would have figured you'd be the only survivor?
Anyways, are you getting along with the chief?
Straight up, I was waiting for you the whole time.
Yeah, I know.
Don't be mad at me, man.
Don't glare at me like that.
The chief will wake up.
Really, I'm sorry.
The other chief must be rolling on the floor with laughter.
Hello talk.
Vision ring? What does vision ring do?
I think we'll be fine to understand what he's doing.
Vision ring is how you scan for enemies.
Wasn't that what I was doing?
Which side should I go first?
There's two hallways now.
Large hall?
Hmm?
Wait, who the fuck is this?
Samantha's sitcom.
Not sitcom?
Please, be careful, sir.
Where did she come from?
Am I holding a giant harman?
That's the harman?
I'm the mother of this sacred place.
Our four children served their purpose.
They didn't die.
But our other nine children were killed by you.
What do you want from us?
Is it so bad that we have a purpose in life?
We are only serving our gods.
At Heaven's command, we will kill the unwanted.
Let's get rid of bad trees from their roots.
I hope you are not one of them.
A white child gets past your bedtime.
Oh my gosh.
Holy shit, he's got a huge gun.
Is this locking on?
You think you killed me?
Better think again.
You have a different voice!
You have a what?
There's faces on your back!
Wait, I can move!
Bye!
I can move!
Kind of creepy.
Bye!
Yes!
I got one of them!
Got another one!
Come on, come on.
No wait, too soon.
Oh shit!
Come on.
I'll go!
Yes!
One more!
Not one.
There we go.
Oh shit.
Revolver moment!
It's not easy to aim like this.
Yes, we got it!
Ah!
Is this the way?
Oh look, I'm wheeling!
They see me rolling, they hate me, they're trolling.
Again!
I thought I killed you, bitch!
Hi, slot!
Oh sorry, I forgot I had to hold this.
Who's that thing popping around?
Where's the guy?
Got it.
Alright, guy from Tekken.
Ah yes, nothing has changed for 30 years, no matter how many times you try, the result will be the same.
Ah yes, like our chess games, you always seem to win.
You're a bad player, senpai.
You're a good friend, but unfortunately, our interest is not mutual.
We both have become burdened with so much, and we don't have time for fun anymore.
There's always time for fun.
Let's dance.
Did I hit his hand?
Oh weeeeee! Why did he fly?
Why did he fly like that?
Okay!
What's a PDA again?
Personnel device something?
Personnel digital assistant, thank you. Personnel display.
Angel complete! We finished!
Exterminated heaven smile.
Okay, that's okay.
The day when laughter disappears from this world draws near.
Continue to sunset.
I was three off from the coveted number.
No laughs?
Oh yeah, I didn't laugh this time.
Almost funny number means it wasn't funny, therefore I didn't laugh.
2010 winter.
Look I can move these, look I can move it.
Is that sunset?
Not funny, didn't laugh.
Is that red moon?
May I ask you to think about these?
Think about what?
Is it these nuts?
I feel like that was a lie.
Oh.
Wait, that sounds nice.
Wait, that sounds fine.
Wait, ideology?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, no, no.
That's not peace!
In the year 2002, a network of intercontinental expressways bridging the Atlantic Ocean opened,
connecting the two major sides of the world.
We have to drive
The construction of a mass-scale distribution system began and the man-made landmass as large as a city
Was built over an ocean
The use and research of nuclear energy was banned and all radioactive waste and materials were disposed of where at an energy
Disposal facility in the Gibbs soft islands. Is that good set of islands off the coast of the Indian Ocean
Is this anime international eyes were on the elimination of the intercontinental missiles that posed the biggest threat to world peace
In order to eliminate these weapons of mass destruction
They were launched outside the Earth's atmosphere and intercepted by other missiles
Exploding them on contact
People around the world watch these explosions light up the sky as if they were some kind of dazzling light show
These explosions later known as the missile show missiles became the symbol of world peace
Wait, isn't that kind of violent for a world peace new threat was on the rise
At the signing ceremony of the UN's world security treaty in the year 2003 a new breed of terrorists who called themselves
smiling faces
The devastating attack caught the international society by surprise and
temporarily crippled key operations in the United Nations
That assault was aimed at nothing other than using terrorism to create terror
Well fear spread throughout the nations like people die when they are killed
There was nothing the police of the military could do to counter the smiling faces
The only one who had any chance of stopping these smiling faces
Were the omniscient and almost godlike professional assassins
The key players behind the scenes of the four powers utilized their connections and called upon the group known as
Killer seven
Their only hope rested with them. Oh my gosh, they title dropped it
Yes, the election is right. Yeah, have you decided on your vote? Yeah
Have a nice day
Yeah, right that's cinnamon toast crunch
What the fuck was that
What the fuck is that
Give me a second
She be
She be is that you she be what you want to eat
Make it fast, okay, I have to go to class at nine
Give me a second. Oh
He's on lockdown
Okay, I have to be him now
The master is awake, what do you change outfit?
Okay
As you wish master remember senpai uncount your butthole
An old friend is trying to bring down a country I will contact you
If there are visitors for me call
As you wish
Samantha the lights as you wish master
It's time can I go now? Yeah. Yeah, you can go now
Thanks
See you tomorrow then
How much money did she did he give for her to be like smoochy
Can I talk to him still
Okay
Oh
Again do I have to do this
Senpai I think you're going crazy the basement is making a lot a lot of sounds
Senpai behave you're causing a disturbance to everyone and the neighbors
Oh
Mercy door stuck door stuck please let us out. Well, why would I do that?
Are you planning to hurt my feeling we're in Seattle Washington DC national events Department of Defense
Wait, that's not the pentagram. That's the star
Done wait, look at this. Yeah, we're looking what is this a bug in the system. No, sir
It's reading right. There's two hundred two hundred what the hell
Disappear off the map. Do you have the impact point yet? Yes, sir. It's Japan. What are the fireworks ready?
No, forget it. Japan is our ally. No, we're not authorized to make that kind of decision forget authorization
We have to do something now or else. We goodbye Japan happen get the president on the line
This is an emergency call for the president
Mr. President this is Spencer speaking sir
200 pulsars have been fired towards Japan. We're unable to compute their trajectory since we're avoiding the computation time lag
Interception can only commence two hours before initial impact
Should we launch the fireworks mr. President your assessment, sir
We're gonna have to do this again to Japan twice is this gonna be a third time
Oh
Yeah, we're gonna do this the third time the third impact
Have been launched where they hit it
Japan
Oh, I got a nice card. What'd you say restaurant Fukushima? It's a popular joint
The owner of the place Toro Fukushima
See he's the middleman between the Japanese UN representatives in our government
Government job
That's a job from all the parties. Japan is turned against us. So that's why they're gonna hit Japan
It depends on how they move it'll be a blow all right
What will happen to Japan?
It's up to the president. They have 18 hours
All hell's gonna break loose over in washington and I sure as hell don't want to be there
If for some reason you need help go see a guy named Kasai. He's well informed. It's especially about the Japanese movement
You got all the details in there, okay
This time the string puller is Fukushima. Now the integrity and the true man is at stake here
Oh
Ha ha ha ha ha ha
All right
Decisive battle at the Japanese restaurant Fukushima
assignment number 34
Get rid of the governor Toro
Fukushima
I uh
Huh
Uh, I rip world peace
He was out of
Master this is bad. This is very very bad. This is their nest
Sure, it looks like a sushi joint. I want to get sushi
But they got terrible taste and I have to admit of course here's dynamite
In the name of Harman
Oh, wait, you've been here before you uh, he was out of
Will you treat us mercy, um
Sushi's kind of expensive senpai we have to go do an all you can eat
Ha ha ha
You have to go to an eye you can eat and everyone has to has to pretend to be one person. Okay. We're all gonna get a giant coat
Uh, we're gonna get a giant coat. We're gonna pay for one extra
Ticket for one, please
What kind of sushi do you normally get I usually get sashimi or nigiri my favorite is uh salmon
We can pretend we're a hive mind
Yes
I heard that the sushi here is cheap though and that it's to die for
Would you
I like, um
Salmon and then I like
mackerel
and then
I like, um
tuna, uh, if you ever go to japan
um
Well when I went there was a huge shortage of salmon so there was no salmon, but the megudo was good
Oh, yeah, here's a funny story senpai. Here's a funny story. So I was talking to
to uh
Uh, some japanese people, right and I was like
Oh, um
Yeah, I was teaching them like english words, right
And then they were like, oh, what's like, uh, what's your favorite sushi?
And then I was like, uh mackerel and they were like
Meguro, no no mackerel
Meguro
So it was like a back and forth between like no, no, I said mackerel
Eagle
And then I was I was like, oh it's sabba sabba this
Sabba this
This is
And they're like, oh
It was fun
Nuts nuts shit
Ow, why are you so slow destiny
Why are you so slow?
Rock
Oh rock
Is word of the day meguro have a macro how many in your party sir seven I want to talk to the owner
May I ask what it's concerning?
Yeah, I'm here to kill mr. Fukushima
Certainly will be delighted to serve you
Oh, I thought I had to do that myself
I'm walking away
Yeah, sorry, I'm walking away. There's a fire there. That's oh, that's uh, not safe
I also wanted to go here
Oh
Save
What I didn't even get blood from that lame
What
Can I wake up dan
Did he just say k
Okay
Judge I'll take care of them
You should I use coyote instead
I
Select
Oh, what a nice shirt. Oh, it's not paisley. It's grapes. There's grapes on this shirt
You got anything to say no
Wait, wait, hold on. I want to see coyote special attacks
Master we're in a tight spot
This skill is extraordinary. The thief is a ruthless villain
Use the white button while holding the gun with the R button
And use one test tube this creates a custom magnum shell
Sure, it's banned by international treaties
But it's just the thing to take out the enemy
In the name of harman
Okay, okay, okay
Oh, and then there's counter attacks to I'll take a look at that
I'll take a look at that mass special ability
Master
We're in a tight spot
The skill is extraordinary. The mask man has strange powers
Use the white button while holding the launcher with the R button
One test tubes for a shock shell
Two for a focus shell
Use it on solid enemies the name of harman
Eh, yeah, yeah
Master this is bad bad news. There's no way to talk
You inflame blame the enemy
The solve matters
You must get in their face draw them closer the moment the enemy flashes
Press the X button for critical
Oh, okay
Do it right and you understand why you guys are not to be messed with in the name of harman. Okay, okay
The other cool infos that I miss growth. Okay, don't don't
Master this is bad, I mean really bad
You have to power up our personas weapons persona
Or the enemies will have the best of us
Rumor has it
Some enemies don't explode
Keep taking the hordes out
And heightened consciousness level up like there's no tomorrow with boosted weapons the enemies will shudder with fear
The name of harman
Oh
Not gonna lie
Senpai, uh, I was seeing screenshots of smt-5 vengeance
Vengeance is a vengeance
Uh, whatever the apocalypse one and I was just like
Oh
Shit, I kind of want it, but then I'm also like oh, but like five I got really dizzy and I couldn't play it
So I don't know. I don't know. I I have mixed feelings
I I have mixed feelings about it, you know
I have mixed feelings it got it gave me motion sickness, but I might be able to do it if there's no motion if I can do it again
Yeah, motion sickness strikes again, I think I liked four because it was on the ds
I
About smt-3 remaster
Did that game give you motion sickness? Oh, not as much. It didn't give me as much motion sickness
But but I wasn't really moving in this like kind of open world thing. I guess
So, yeah
So does playing in windowed mode help? Um
Not really not really to be honest
Um
Not really
It doesn't matter what side I think a smaller screen is better though, but it's still kind of like oh, I'm still kind of dizzy, you know
Um, I don't like smt-3 that much because it's really punishing and hard
I'm a baby. I'm a baby when it comes to gaming. I want my games to be relaxing and easy
so that's why I play on easy mode and then
Don't tell other smt fans that I play on easy mode because it's uh
I like I like I like relaxing and going with the story and then
um
SMT fans will be like, why aren't you playing it on hard? Why are you playing it hard? What is wrong with you?
So that's our little secret, okay
That's our little secret
Haha
We're in a tight spot. This feel is extraordinary. This brat can run like the wind
Perfect for long tracks
He'll run like dickens anywhere anytime
Press the y button to use it
The name of Harman
Oh
My arms a little bit
My arms a little bit what do you call it? Um
Acting up so I might have to go ice it some pie
Yeah
I have to go ice it again probably
Oh, yeah, by the way, I hate matador. I hate matador
The moment I got to matador and sm t3. I was like son of a whore
Isn't it both arms now? Yeah, it's both arms, but one arm is way more than than the rest
Anyways, I'm gonna go ice it
Yeah
We all ice it
Well, I'm gonna grab ice and then no wait. Can I I can't play with one hand shit. We're gonna have a little uh
Yap session when I come back with the ice. Yeah
Yeah, and then we'll uh, yeah
Yeah
I'll be right back
So
Are you are you playing ping pong?
Senpai
Well senpai I am icing my arm right now
Right
Now so uh, I have to hold it on my arm so I can't play the game until it's like iced again
So everyone
Why do you always play ping pong? Why is it ping pong?
Settle in for some yapping. Yeah, we'll do a little bit of yapping
Before I continue well, I'll put this back back down by the sink and then if I need it again, I'll just pick it up again
so um
Yeah, my arm is very very very itchy. It looks so much better
Than it did like two days ago
Senpai like two days ago
It looks so bad. It looks so bad. I was like
Luckily all the games I was playing were like super easy or like could be played with one hand
Like you know
Any like walking stuff or like visual novels. It's just like dun dun dun dun dun. This one requires me to be actually you know
Good
So
Um, I was able to like rest my ice pack beside me and then kind of like just play with one hand
But um
Maybe you should change the schedule then uh, I still want to play killer seven
We'll just have to ice it so my arms when they flare up like they get so hot
That the ice melts that the ice melts and I can't even feel that the ice pack is cold
But if I put it like on my leg or something it's it's like oh, it's cold
But it feels like
It's not
When I put it on
It doesn't even feel cold
Uh
Fortunately killer seven isn't very intense. Yeah, it's not intense, but I it still requires two hands
But um, yeah, the doctor was checking the rest of my body to see if uh
Uh
If she could see if there were any anywhere else that it happened and she's like, oh, yeah, you got some on your legs
and
Uh, as I was at the doctor, I was like rashing up on the other side
On the other arm. I was like, ah
You know, I have a fever call. Hi. That's the first thing I checked. The first thing I checked was okay now. It's cold. Um
Um
The first thing I checked and mama mama mercy checked was uh
Was was to see if I had a fever
And
And uh, she was like, oh no, no
There's no fever. So we're good there
Time to wash everything in your life. Trust me. I already did
Uh, right now my my bed sheets are in
the laundry
Do you ever find the cause of the rash? I have no idea. I have no idea senpai
I have no idea
I literally woke up
And I was like my arm's really itchy. Why and then suddenly my entire arm became
Like very quickly when I woke up
Became all rash and I was like panicking. I was like, oh my god. What do I do?
Oh
It's very itchy. That's probably
the most
Annoying part of it and it's on my dominant arm. I think the most itchiest parts are like at the wrist and the elbows
So that's why I was like
I took a shower just in case it was like an allergy like contact allergy and it was still there. So I was like, oh
The food allergies, um, I don't know
Usually if I have a food allergy, it's like the entire body
goals into
goals until like
issue
Maybe you have bed bugs. Um
highly unlikely
And I'm pretty because these are definitely not bites because I went to the doctor
She was like, oh, yeah allergies is definitely something allergy related
Um, do you use ac? Uh, no, actually it's been quite cold recently
No changes in washing detergents or anything. No
No, nothing
Thank you for the super chat charlie
I'm not reading that
Sorry not right now not right now
Maybe new clothes. Yeah. Yeah, maybe maybe it's new clothes. I mean like
It did happen when when uh, mama mercy
Mama mercy was like, oh, I'm gonna give you my old clothes
And I said, okay, so I got her old clothes that she wore when
Um
When she was like younger and then I guess I wore some of those and I don't know maybe
Maybe
It would have been that but it was like washed
That might be the reason
but
I don't know it could have been
the
Like polyester or something
But then that doesn't explain it because then I like took off the clothes
And like I haven't worn it for like days. I'm wearing my old clothes
Right now I'm wearing
A really ugly dress
This is like one of the things that I'm just like, oh, well, this shouldn't hurt
So I've been wearing nothing but like 100 100 cotton t-shirts
So I was like, oh man
Can't be ugly if Cole High's wearing it. It's paisley
It's like well, it's one of mama's old clothes. It's like paisley. It's like purple paisley
But yeah
It's really ugly
Can't be that bad. Oh the pattern's pretty ugly like it's it's pretty ugly
Is that the word of the day paisley wait the senpai's not know what paisley is
I
Think paisley is rad really I feel like it's such a grandma pattern
I thought the word of the day with macro. Yeah, I made it macro, but now I'm wondering if I could change it because senpai's don't know what paisley is
Yeah, it's like a teardrop shape pattern with like a lot of uh, mini patterns in it. It's pretty ugly
It's pretty ugly, but um
Yeah, this is I'm wearing mama's mama's old clothes
Isley can be good, I guess like in small okay, can I get my other arm now in small doses doses, but like
But like it's definitely ugly. Oh, I think it's fine. It's got like a nice, um
Oh
Like a nice cut, uh, don't guilt trip me in soup buzz senpai
Don't guilt trip me in soup buzz
Senpai naughty acid bath
As a bath time senpai. I really appreciate it, but
Senpai aren't you naughty
I
I'll how about I read it at the end of stream when I'm in the
When I'm in the mood right now my arms flaring and my and my uh
My arms flaring and I'm just like
As much as I want to go wink wonk, I'm just like
I
Do appreciate it though. I do appreciate it
Oh my legs
Thank you for the soup uh paisley fan art. I don't know paisley's not
I don't know
You have artistic freedom, but
But oh that's so grandma kawar
You sure you're fine. Yeah, yeah, yeah
Yeah, I'm I'm fine. Don't worry senpai. We're just icing things right now
Well other senpais be okay, of course. I mean
those
Those who are you know
not little
Oh, oh biaches
Not not saying that like
Not saying that like anyone here is but
Senpais we'll get okay fine fine senpais get
Okay, how about this all my days off all my days off. Oh, we'll have a deal. We'll have a deal
All my days off you get freedom
How about that you get to be outside the cage on my days off
You just have to wear a tracking device at all times that is uh smelted to your body
Smelted
It'll be just like you know state controlled
You can choose to stay in the cage, but I'll let you go
You'll always come back though senpai
It shocked me if I go too far
Um, it can have it's like, you know the neck bombs
If you go out of a certain radius boom
But for our feet, yeah, so as you always know it will be it will just remind you you can't run
What's the radius to the nearest mcdonald's out of the country?
I'll be I'll be so so generous senpai. I'll be so generous. I'll be until the next town in all directions
So generous one town over
Mm-hmm, but the moment you step out of those town those town boundaries or if you go underground
I will know the moment that signal is lost. Kabooie
Kabooie
What if there's a cheese case factor in the next town I said and up
You can it's include it's included in the next town
Like big metropolis
Uh town or boonies town. Oh half and half
I guess it's kind of like normal
I don't know. I don't know. I don't know how like what normal is it has a downtown
It has a downtown and big buildings big business buildings. It's still it's still like a nice place to visit
Thank you senpai for the five super please drink response to play response to boy
I don't know. I wouldn't call it a city. I wouldn't call it a city. I would call it like a town still
Oh man
A principality, I don't know like it still has like malls and stuff so
buildings
But I don't think it's particularly huge, you know
I don't think it's particularly huge. It'll be like, I don't know. I would still consider it a town
Then again huge my differ between people
Basement is all we need. Is there a population minimum we're considering? Uh, I don't know
I don't know maybe 500,000 700,000 is a town, right?
And I trade the tracker in and instead be a house husband
I know how to cook. What can you cook? What is your best meal?
and
okay, well
Make sure your liver's okay if you're drinking
A town is about 10% of that. Oh
Okay, then the next city over you'll have so much ability to move
I may not be able to cook but I have great credit score and stable mental health
Okay, you know what that's that's that's one up from a lot of us. I have
I have a lot of I have meadow illinois
As all vtubers do. I mean, I told you I told you I had like my weekly breakdown
So, uh, but I can make phone calls. I can make phone calls and appointments
I
Can make appointments and phone calls and I can drive so I don't know one step closer
That's one step closer to like, you know
Oh and my credit score is fine too my credit score is fine
Oh
Driving what a showoff. Yeah, I drive I drive the family minivan
Oh, you laugh like a dolphin. That's it. I know I know I know
There are several laughs that I have
I think
I've been called a windshield wiper. I've been called a squeaky door. I've been called a dolphin
Are you an aggressive driver? Not particularly. I consider myself a defensive driver
T kettle is what I think of I think most people say it's windshield wiper
Or like, you know, when you put windex on a cloth and go squeak squeak squeak, that's what some of my laughs sound like
Find your laugh really cute. Thank you. I feel like it's one of my, um, charm points
Charm points? Yeah, I think it's one of my charm points
Sometimes I sound like a creaky door too
I
It's one of my charm points definitely something that uh people take notice of even IRL
Uh, I don't know what my other charm points are my inability to read
Okay, we're almost done Senpai. Sorry. Sorry about that
We're almost done
Oh
I think my other charm point would be
Uh, I guess maybe you've noticed I make a lot of mouth noises
A lot of mouth noises where it's like
You're also the first VTuber that plays SMT outside of persona. That's hella charming. What is my charm point the type of games I play?
That can't be that can't be it, right? My gamer scores might it's my um
It's my charm point only if you play knock turn on normal
Uh
Part of it I've never seen anyone play harvester I
Seriously, I feel like I played very early on and when I started streaming
Uh, that's such a long time ago when I say such a long time ago. That's like three years
three years ago, um
I
Play nothing about pointing clicks. So now I'm running out of pointing clicks. I'm running out of pointing clicks to play
I mean I could play it again, but I don't know it just loses this magic if you like play again
I mean with the crowd I think
I
Can't play visual novels next I have
two visual novels
that I want to I want to read
with senpai one is completely uh
Not great
One is completely not great and probably would be a turnoff to a lot of people, but I'm waiting for uh
Oh
It's an ad friendly. No, I'm waiting for the uh, hold on
Streams
And the other one I'm thinking is dona dona
Uh
But the other one is uh
Is uh
Poilet stuff
Let's just say that
It's a bit it's a funny considered the worst one of the worst vns
Ever made
It's not great, but it is comedic
It is comedic and it's really gross. It's really gross
I think some of you already know it. I see it in chat already
I see it in chat already. I think it'll be funny at least
It's gross
But funny
So I think that'll be an interesting stream
Definitely not one where you're like
I'm gonna jork it's more like morbid curiosity
I'm gonna I'm that's my
That's my
You know assumption my assumption
My assumption I mean like I'm not gonna I'm not gonna shame you for what you like but at the same time
I'm going to guess
It's
Not exactly like a a a a
It's one that people are going to miss out on yes, just because of the subject
Just because of the subject so I think that one is
For fun and I definitely don't expect anyone to be like
I'm I'm cumin
I don't expect anything
Anyone to be like I'm cumin and I'm expecting a much less big audience for that one than my other ones
I'm also interested in playing. Um
Some really gory ones
Like I think what was it megad bites bites is that one?
Uh and
I
Megan baits. Yeah baits. Yeah
Um
And
Maybe muvelove muvelove I hear muvelove is like one of those games that it's like a must to play
Well the stream is on the other platform be paywall. No it will not
uh
I'm planning what I'm planning for the other stream
Is uh for a little funsy onesie
Um, it's free as long as you follow because we don't want any uh, we don't want any trouble
We don't want any twubble right so it's free if you follow and uh
With some incentives
Yeah
For donations very uh
Interactive incentives, yes
But yes, it will be free
It will be free. I don't plan on like
Paywalling that it's a streaming site. I feel like it's it shouldn't be pay walled
Incentives to help keep the vibes, yeah
Yeah
Yeah, the good vibes going
We're free of course
Um, but you have to in my plan my plan is that you have to follow
And also, um, I don't know. I don't know but I saw a lot of people asking if like vods will be like up
Uh, you see the thing is on the other website. There is no vods. There are no vods vods do not get saved
So I don't think so
Oh, yeah, I people are like, oh, can we watch the mods for free and I'm like, I don't even think there is vods
There I don't think there is vods
Yeah, you recorded yourself. Yeah, I don't feel like that maybe
The question is where to host it. I know. Oh, yeah, uh hosting stuff seems
hard
I'll I'll I'll talk to strongy about it. I'll talk to strongy and management about it when the time comes
Because uh, right now I want to focus on my youtube stuff
I want to focus on my youtube stuff or for funsies
and also because, um
You know
In the end I do want to be seen as like sort of
Not not I don't want to be seen as
A brand risk
Oh, okay, that sounds so bad when I say it. I don't want to be seen as like a brand risk where I I might like, um
Um
I might I might cause some of my friends company to be like, no, no, you can't you can't collab with with her. I don't want that
I don't want that. Oh, I'll wait for like 10k. Maybe I'll wait until 10k for like fans extremes. Who knows?
So
Yeah, I just want to be sure. Oh, what did I didn't censor? Oh man, my bad
You didn't hear that
um
I don't want I don't want to like, uh, I don't want to make people uncomfortable, right? Like public a public facing
I want to be seen as
Uh pretty decent, but uh privately. I'm just uh in alternate places. Uh, we're free. We got free reign. We got free reign
You got free reign
You only stream on youtube. Yeah, I only stream on youtube. Yeah
Anything that I said before that was all fake fake news
Um
Yeah, I just want to make sure that when it comes to corpals because I have a lot of friends
in like different corporal
Which I I would love to you know, uh
It was uh
Definitely something that I want
I want to like hang out with my other friends and I don't want to become like a brand risk where it's like
Oh, I can never work with my friends ever again, you know
But I definitely don't mind having that other image. Uh
Behind behind places where if you want that content you search for it
That's kind of thing
Viola is kind of a brand risk in itself. I think personally some pie
I think we're really not that different from any other, uh companies
There's a lot of companies that also do uh alternate. Um
asmr stuff
so
I feel like um
We're not
Really different from any other company. Um
The advertisement as we are a little bit on the the the spicier side. I feel like that's definitely to capture attention
That's definitely to capture attention and we do advertise advertise it
But that's the only difference
I
Don't think it's even as spicy or other corpse can get away with with it
Yeah, it's the kind of hook
It's a bit more I feel like it's not as spicy in my opinion
I feel like it's quite normal
Okay, okay, um senpai's I'm gonna have to go up again and put away the ice pack because it's completely melted here
It's completely melted
So I'm gonna put it back in the freezer
So
Senpai's playing games here, okay now we now we're gaming
Now we're gaming I'm sorry about the long intermission senpai. Sorry about the long intermission
Yeah, it looks like I I'll be able to continue playing
Okay, we're gonna game we're gaming
I need to click on the screen
There it is
But yeah
Fruitful fruitful conversation. I hope I hope
That's my plan. Um, at least that's my plan
but if uh
If management's like no or if scrawny's like, I don't know then uh all that plan gone
All that plan is gone
Or our might change a bit
Coyote
master
In a tight spot
The skill is extraordinary the thief loves high places
You can jump like a human flea damn
Shall I say a master of trespassing?
Press the y button to use it
In the name of harman
Okay, so this is me anything else combat. Okay, we're good
It might take a little bit getting used to these guys
Idea I thought the only idea was youtube. Yeah. Yeah, you're getting it senpai
You get it
Ah everything's on fire the length I took should have waiting room
Shit
Why are you so fast?
Oh
He ran away
Oh we did it
Again
How many are you?
I
Like it when you crawl wait, there's more
Yeah
Why didn't it go? Okay
Oh hi travis. I'll carry your pigeon. Hold on. Let me look at that one
Oh
Dear amir, this is a warning amir transfer hundred dollars in my account. I'm absorbing a twenty five dollar loss final offer. All right, mary
Nothing terrible has happened yet
It's time for you to send the money consider it a gift for me to use surprisingly the smith syndicate has many talents
And I ain't talking about cheap tricks like swallowing goldfish or cramming your head into a rubber glove
They're on a whole other plane. I saw it with my own eyes heroes for our age
dan smith is a straight out of
japanime
Launching balls of light and shit. Yeah, you bet it blew my socks off. Heck. I wanted to shake his hand and ask for an autograph
But I decided to put my life first
Oh
Kai day smith sports blood from her arms
What a sick sight and then what did she do? She flattened a wall right before my eyes. She must have taken out some kind of barrier
That's what kai day's blood can do
Sometimes her arms suck blood. That's some stuff. I didn't need to see either
Masked a smith is still a mystery
But I do know that he can do some sweet wrestling moves
He was a small town pro wrestler who drew crowds to main events
But just before he made his debut in the new york scene. He mysteriously disappeared
This is common knowledge amongst fans
The only thing for sure is that there's more than meets the eye and updated an update will follow johnny gar gegner gegner
gegner
Contain your ear
Where
Son of a bitch
I'm in the middle of talking here
Do you mind if I tell you straight up
I heard it through the grapevine number one chief. You're not the only one after the owner of this joint
The pan is controlled by the nash united nations party
The un party goes down
Pan's minority party will take control
In other words the liberal party will take the reins
There's some nasty shit cooking in this restaurant
And it ain't mama's fried chicken
The thief from south america could climb in this in a in a jiffy
What's the
So
How many are there
Oh, come on out again
I
Shit is it behind me
I forgot how to do a quick turn senpai
Yeah
Shall we
Be button
All right, I'm kind of dumb
I'm kind of dumb
It's fine maybe
Oops
Oh, we got the body already nice
Look i'm a cleaner I can feel no remorse. Okay body to me. It's nearly as a wreck riding flesh a bud
I
Yay
You
Okay, we're gonna put some blood in I'm gonna have to level up guys. I think I'm gonna have to level up
You must defeat three enemies to wake him up
And judge I'll take care of them
You
Okay, fine, we'll use him this is kind of hard
I
Maybe I should go back
Oh, he's so slow
Fuck it
I wanted to use the the the the sneaking thing
Didn't get any blood see like I
I have no one
Oh
The ego has landed on the roof
Anyone else
Oh
Can I use the blood to heal
Was it oh, hi
Well, hello Smith raining today, isn't it you know what I never go to school when it rains
But my mom doesn't understand
Stupid mom without her reasons
She says go to school. So I jumped down from the second floor
In that calm that's a compound fracture my new pulverized them all splat absolutely faux barred
Took six months to heal. I got to take half a year off from school
Whoopee you forgot this didn't you?
Watering returned
Not a single classmate came to visit me in the hospital
Well, what about her of course she didn't come
She jumped with me
And I landed on top of her like the coolest thing, you know, I'll leave the rest of your imagination
My imagination of a killer
Okay, bye
Okay, I have the ring now have the ring now night
Water
Mom okay, I don't think mom's okay
I have a I have a slight feeling that mommy is not okay
Okay
Okay, hold on there's probably some guy
Oh
Stuck it
Uh
Oh
Did you just say you're fucked
Because I felt that
The hallway was I supposed to go into again? That's not the right one is it?
Oh, yeah here it is courtyard
Which way oh hi. Oh shit
Oh, that was so close
Oh
I don't know which way
Est let's go est hi travis
The cold rain this evening is like my damn tears you hear me no not again
A blood red flower is gonna go up like a firework like tears in her in the rain
Enough to the owner Fukushima to prevent it from hitting and killing everybody
So chief which side are you on the homeland or japan?
If you kill the owner japan goes down the toilet
Are you all right with that man careful of the new enemy type
Oh
I hope we get a save point soon
Bomb head
Oh you're fucked I did it
Oh
Don't make me say it again
What
I
I'm shag
Does this mean I lose all my blood I collected so many
I
Bitch
Oh
Can I reload again?
There we go you got it
Look I'm a cleaner I can feel no remorse. Let's be the dead body
Thank you for the super
Oh
Thank you for the orange super
This is hard this is hard senpai this is hard
Please let there be enough blood so I can dump it into people
What
Must defeat three more yeah skills I need your stuff to
I need you to to have stuff now
Should I do speed he needs to be faster right?
Or power maybe power attack power
No, I can induce speed too. No. Yes, I can
Okay, yeah, let's all level one everything. Yeah
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah
Let's see if this makes a difference
I
Just in case
There you go
The
Harmon's we can save here
It's a
Save bitches
I'm gonna go here sunset
Let's look at the TV again
Wow, I didn't have that much blood dang it
Oh man
Wait, can I go back in there can I farm blood here?
Oh
What
No, I need to abilities down attack charge shot
Judge I'll take care of them
You need more speed you need more speed you definitely need more speed
Okay, I can't farm anymore they knew my methods
They knew my method
I
Pardon
Went over there
Oh
Mask
Mask maybe
No, hi there
I'm a ghost kind of girls
Area destroyed
Should I change it I'm gonna change it just in case there's like a big boss there
Oh
Egg me Dan here
Oh shit
Son of a bitch
We're fine
I'm fine
If you have a minute to share good share
It could open your eyes
Pan doesn't have its own defense system
Its survival is contingent in the United States as far as the homeland is concerned Japan is extra baggage
Its usefulness as an ally is long past
Straight up it ain't worth saving you see
That's reality for you so chief you still gonna do it
You
Know what it's meant by fireworks. They're missiles explosion that occur when missiles
Collide oh sure. It's a beautiful sight indeed
But you'll only see it if the defense system is activated
Really I went all the way here and all I got was Travis a
Haha travesty
If you will
What the fuck is that spiral smile
I like it
We got it
Oh shit
It's too far away from the
There we go
Where's it? Where's it? Where's it? Oh shit, it's right there
Oh
Run
Mace watering howls
The cherry blossom bloom fully
Thank you
Didn't even have to listen to it
Obtained odd engraving
I
Can talk to you once mr. Smith
I saw information. Yes
They important ah
Flower must bloom
Think of a way to make it happen
Shoot the mask to hear more
But the mask lost for thick blood
I did it at once. I don't want to do it again
I want I want a room soon
Yes
Shit hi, why are you sitting like that?
Take my blood
I
Don't make me say it again. She's you still are an ugly fella
Kevin Smith, let's awaken everyone. Yeah, I need
Where should I put it in
Where should I put it in some pie
I think waiver power everything in power
And to call
You can't just ask that mercy. Why not the perfectly innocent question
Fatality is still good though
And I want to save point
Downstairs
Wait, there was another room right hold on was there another room no, there was just Harman's room hold on sorry
I
Power lunch
The owner Fukushima is mixed up in all sorts of things even the International Ethics Committee is getting involved
Chief you watch yourself
The ethics agents or hyenas are a motley crew of rejects, but the assassins trained in the core
Now those guys are what about after the Yakumo party cabinet policy or Yakumo for short
It's just a bunch of paper, but it can change the world you end party my friend
I'm getting tired Senpai
Oh, I'm not doing so hot though
I don't remember which face bitch
Come on open your head
Senpai it turned into a square
There's nothing here
Oh
Did he just clean his shoe with his gun
Wait, I'm lost wait Senpai I'm lost I didn't go this way did I?
I
Don't think I've been this way yet
Or
Yeah
Block deactivated
I
Fine I want a room
I mean yes
Oh
Me to carry your pigeon
Continuing my report Kevin Smith never fails to amaze you won't believe this but it's the straight-up truth
The sucker is a real-life invisible man. Oh
Plenty I teach an interesting name
Why must they taught me like that?
At first even I didn't believe it. This has got to be a hoax, right? Oh shit the guys for real and
Then con Smith what a pain in the ass punk?
I can never catch him it blows my socks off nine times. He speeds off. He disappears
That's right. This appears Olympic records mean nothing with him running around
Coyote Smith has a thing a
Thing for being a crook, but he's not like other thugs. He's fit. He jumps like an animal incredible
Athleticism not to mention he can pick any padlock
Must pick this up as a method of survival in a rough neighborhood and then there's Garcia and Smith
I really haven't seen much seeing him much so everything. I know is based on conjecture
You and rumor has it he can spot the heavens mile a mile away
This character is no joke going up against monsters like that. My investigation continues Johnny Gagman
Is this the way it was Zaru you spoke to me again
Master, this is bad
It's just can't be good at all
Be sure about that mask
Master you must have doubts or I would think I'm wearing a bit. That's for sure
Whenever you get in tight spot you break out your silly wrestling moves. I can't you bury the past
By the way, your special size suplex move should be banned the name of Harmon
Lumber essential for training
All right, you know what this means mask this Smith
Oh
He just suplexed that
What's in your right hand Chico
Please don't this is just a put your arms down
Oh, no, no, it's not like that this gun is it don't move amigo. Don't move amigo shoot stay still
Is a kitchen cleaning up that you can lick the floor
Anyway, it's the least that I can do for them the others the chef the waiters
Where are they those guys with the strange smiles? You saw them. It's dangerous. Okay. Get out of here. I
Have a feeling you're up to no good
I
Point say point say point say point
Why is she so mean to me why is she so mean to me
What
Where's the same point I don't remember which way am I facing
I
Where am I
I'm there there's not a safe point until up there
I
Can crawlin ass biatch
Not shots Jesus fucking Christ
It's a Feng shui man
I
Mr. Smith I saw information. Yes, look closely at that sign
Big hit right in front of you car no directions in the mythical beast can't be a part no
I
Must come together
To the mask we hear more
But the mask lust for thick blood
Okay, so what
Oh
The turtles name again, I forgot what the turtles name was
Hey, so there's the turtle
view
Phoenix that other one
Getting boo. Yeah
Yeah, yeah, yeah, thanks. That's the turtle right?
turtles north
Dragon is
East Phoenix a cell. Oh
I don't know what that is
Is west west
Tiger yeah, again boo say real Suzaku yackle. Oh, yeah, right yackle
Oh
North or east
All the way west house
Master
This is bad
I feel that it's very very bad. I just have to figure it this feeling that I've seen that sushi chef before
Recognize that I'm full of myself and my manliness. No look
It's all a shura charade. I tell you a phony
All looks at nothing more
I don't care what you say master
This one man I cannot accept
No, it's not because he's more handsome than me nothing of the sort never
Just can't forgive the rat the name of Harmon
Wait tiger
This is the west corridor, right
Oh
Shit, where's it? Oh, there it is. Come on
Yo, we better reload not gonna lie kind of creepy kind of scary kind of a lot
Hello
Never mind
Never mind that's a lot
Welcome to the stream
See point
Yeah
I've been
I'm out the same point and finally we made it
I killed so many guys I have to have blood now, right?
blood
blood for the blood god
I only got one serum shit
Geez you still are an ugly fella. How's it been, huh?
What's up, Dan?
Yeah
Hold on I'm gonna I gotta put some more stuff into you range
Yeah, let's do your explosion range bigger
Ah
I'm gonna save again
I've been to three rooms and they all had no say points. How mean is that everyone? That was so mean, right some pie?
Oh, I'm tired
I'm tired some pie. I did so much shooting I
I I was I was being teased until the end
That was not very very poggers of them
I don't know what no, no, no, yeah, I
Did the shooting I finished the last part that was pretty cool actually the beginning which felt like the tutorial
was um
Was
What's what's kind of fun kind of
But now they wrap things up so much. I'm just like
I'm so bad at this. I can't shoot. I I can't shoot
I
Can't shoot shooting is hard. Thank goodness. I took my pills
Well, please don't ever say that sentence unironically again, what did I say? I
Took my nausea pills
Was that the one
That wasn't very poggers. Oh, okay. Yeah, it wasn't
What was I saw someone say some new words today
Yeah, this game mugged me
I
We're shoot we're shoot Maxon
Don't know these these darn
New words they come out so fast now. I think it's cuz of tiktok. I think it's cuz of tiktok
They get you yeah, yeah
They get those straight whizzler whizzler me
Oh boy, but some of these some of these guys just pop out of nowhere, and I'm like
I don't get it. It's not it's skibbity, right?
Okay, okay, okay, let's pause the game
We're good. We're good right now. I think I'm sorry. I played I played only about like an hour ish of this
It was I had to ice my arm for most of most of the stream I apologize for that
But now I'm tired and I think it's a result of my nausea pills wearing off a bit I
Think it's cuz of the nausea pills
But yeah, let's go to just chatting
Yeah, oh, hey, okay, I'm gonna flashbang everyone. Okay ready to be flash banged
Yeah, let me let me scoot up a little bit
I
Like it burns it burns our retinas
Okay, okay, okay now let's read super chats. I know I read them briefly a little bit, but I'll read them now
Okay
From Charlie I can give you a fever watch this you've been a good little coal high for your senpai
Next is
So you can read poor Charlie super give the latter break awful
I'm loving of you not to read it. No if you love if you don't love us that means we can go
Yeah, I gotta grab some drinks. Anyway, so toodles
Sorry about the late one. I know James is probably
Drunk now, but I did read it now
From boy Paisley, let's see fan art soon apparently there already is
And also James obviously I have to leave at some point how am I supposed to buy nice things without money
Certainly can't make things
youth
Make you things tied up. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, that's fine
And ironically tipsy to drunk. I don't remember any if tomorrow's a cheers grab more whiskey play nice
And that was still still
You already passed out from being drunk sir
I
Quit quit quit drunk
How can you even see the keyboard?
And so it's okay. You got this. I believe me. Thank you. So I saw the super I was the orange super
I did read that one and I'm really I'm so new to this senpai
I'm so new to like reading Supas and having membas. I'm just like what what is the etiquette?
What is the etiquette of like doing this I know that like I
Know that like a lot of people
A lot of people say things for the end of stream, but I'm just like
That's that's okay, right?
That's okay to like kind of do some of them at the end of stream and some of them like in the middle, right?
I'm not really sure
And I really share
It's your call really
That's good to do either way. It's all about the mullet
And it depends on the screen okay, cuz I'm just like oh, I don't really know
I
Don't really know the etiquette, but whoa, whoa, we'll see
Yeah, we'll see we'll see I'll I'll I'll get it some pie. I'll get it some pie
I'll get it some pie. I'm so new to this. I didn't stream on on YouTube
I didn't stream on YouTube when I was streaming so this is this is all kind of new I did do some
YouTube streams
but
They didn't have rays or anything
They didn't have any of the stuff
I wonder how reading soup buzz and effects engagement I have no idea
The only time I kind of know about soup buzz is
is with like hollow live and
I don't know. I feel like that's kind of we don't play by that rule because
Obviously, it's not as big of a
Of a of a crowd
Different standards. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah
I
Something like that, you know like
I'm just a small fish I'm just a small fish
I'm just a small fish in the sea of beautiful v2 birds
I'm just a small fish with a
strange laugh a
Squawky voice and and a perchance for for murder
I
Perchance incline. Yeah
I'll say you'll notice that I'll say sayings very wrong
You
Your sub count ain't gonna be small fish for
Long with how fast it's expanding you won't be you won't just be a big yo won't just be a big fish soon soon
You'll be jaws
Am I gonna get killed and are pooned right through right through the mouth?
Oh
Perchance just reminded me of the essay. That's what I'm referencing
I wasn't an explosion. I can't remember. Oh, man. It was an explosion, right? Wait. No spoilers
Jaws has been out since
Wait, how long?
No
You mean a second since 1975
Some folks will read soup was but not the name to avoid parasocial and or compare
Heditiveness also God bless autocorrect this Tim and out 11 out of 10 glug glug
Thank you James for the super. I
think um I
Think I can say thank you for
Supas and membas and
Donations I think I can yeah
Yeah, I think I can yeah
Do do some pies some pies not like it when I say names I
Feel like saying the name of like whoever like donated and tipped you it's like I don't know it's nice
I think I think I was I think it was yeah, I feel like management told me I should
I never thought about it that way. I don't think it matters either way. Yeah, I don't know
It's up to me
It's up to me. I think I'll continue saying thank you
I never thought about it like that. Yeah, I never thought about it like that either
I mean I can see why I don't want I don't want some pies to be jealous
Because I love awesome pies equally
They don't want their names read they can always donate anonymously. Oh, that's an idea too. I
Can just say add on anonymous and young young miss and young young miss. Why am I saying it with a list anonymous?
Anonymous
Not a non anonymous
I
And the question how do you manage to fit so many of us into a single cell
It's a big cell really big huge even ginormous
Are you looking forward to the clubs ladies week? Of course. I'm really excited to play with my gen mates
Mostly cuz I love them. I love them a lot. They they comfort me and we play a lot of stuff. Yeah
Thank you for the $2 super, but I'm your favorite, right I
Can't choose favorites. I'm sorry Senpai. I can't choose favorites
Every Senpai is my favorite Senpai except for the Senpais that are that are straighter scum
Okay, except for the Senpais that are traitorous scums
Ah
Senpais are good are great Senpais amazing Senpais
I
Don't want to choose favorites. I honestly do not want to choose favorites because everyone is so precious to me
Thank you for a super chat $5 super chat Raoul Ortiz and you wish me good luck at work tomorrow Marcy. Good luck
Good luck
I'm in
So, yeah
What was the word again?
What was I you? What was I even doing again? Oh shit? I lost my train of
Train of thought I lost my train of thought ice I did I turn offs?
I didn't hear a single Senpai in my in my gaming screen. Did I did I break it?
All up
We were doing something I totally forgot already I
Don't want to play favorites. I don't want to play favorites. I love awesome pipes equally and I hope awesome pies love me
What would you do if you caught a Senpai on the phone well check what's on the phone duh
Check what's on the phone duh
Are you playing games or are you cheating?
I just wanted to repeat the okay
Maybe go over schedule for this week. All right. Sorry. I am like out of it. I am so out of it Senpai
Go minna sigh
I'm E.P. tired emotional
That's my schedule, okay. Well tomorrow I have my day off
So I'm gonna hang out with friends and stuff
Wednesday is death mark again. Well, I know death mark is not a very popular game
But I want to relax and I think that would be really really great if we we all relax
Relax while I read
Thursday is the untitled goose game collab with straw knee so we're going to have a lot of fun with that
And
Followed by that is another day off and then the uno collab which by the way my time is not correct
So please check the other girls's calendars to see if it's correct
Because yeah, it's not correct on my on my schedule
And
Then I have another day off. So I have three days off this week
Hopefully I can recover my arms and my legs and stuff. I
Was a game called death mark relaxing. It's not but it is a visual novel
So it's not like it's not it can be played one-handed
It can be played one-handed and so I don't put strain on like this this this hand
So yeah, I'm trying to
To to rest this arm hopefully it was it won't
Oh
It won't
It is ill it is like a bit time though
So the visual novel has like quick time events, but like I think they're kind of okay quick time events. So it's not
too
Not too stressful. Yeah
She's rest filled Sigma. I don't know what that means. What does Sigma mean?
I
Yeah, quick time events are
Yeah, that one there's some quick time events. I think
There's a little bit at stake. So we'll see we'll see and I was not not too not too fun, but it's uh
It's
Oh
What's the word it's it's it's a game where we can relax and I
Yeah, so that's for the schedule this week
I'm hoping I'm gonna figure out something so I'm hoping to open up membership streams
Uh soon
I don't really know what people do for them for membership streams, but I guess like you just do whatever, right?
So I want to try to do a membership stream
Soon so I don't know when but yeah, I
Want to I want to I don't know if I'm gonna do it this week
Maybe next week, but I want to try to do at least once a week
At least once a week for for members
Remember
So that
So that we can have some fun together
So, yeah, I'm so so tired Senpai, I'm so sorry. I know it's
Now I started the stream kind of rough and
Stuff so I'm gonna just you know
Yeah
Yeah, let's see who's on so we can raid into them
Amy's on and rain is still on
How long how long has we been on I
Might I might
raid into rain
Cuz
She's another you may pass girl. I think it'll be nice to just like introduce you to top to them as well
So, yeah, okay
Let's go and I'll see you all again
Next time
Scream for mercy
You